while the MCU films maybe about
superheroes there are still lowly
fallible humans writing the scripts
running the cameras and working behind
the scenes to make it all happen here's
an affectionate look at some of the
biggest movie mistakes that have
weaseled their way into the MCU so far
Black Widow is as impressive a spy and
assassin as ever walked the planet and
she's demonstrated those talents on more
than one occasion however none of them
were quite as impressive as when she
made her entrance early on in the first
Avengers movie when Black Widow arrives
on the screen she's tied to a chair
surrounded by a bunch of baddies who by
their own calculations are in total
control of the situation
except of course they're not I'm in the
middle of an interrogation this [ __ ] is
giving me everything everything everyone
got a kick out of the ensuing encounter
with Black Widow calmly flipping around
beating the crap out of the astonished
bullies literally with two hands tied
behind her back the only problem at one
point in the struggle she literally
beats back one of the bullies with her
hair in a move that looks like it was
probably supposed to be a headbutt to
the face black widow super charged locks
gently brushed her opponents face only
to send him reeling backward while this
could have been a hint at some odd new
superpowers to come chances are it was
just a poorly filmed stunt that slipped
into the final cut guardians of the
galaxy was a sweet ride and a nice way
for Marvel to expand the MCU into a more
galactic mindset it also was loaded with
laughs many of which traced their way
back to Peter Quill's earth origins
right in the opening scenes we see
star-lord using a cassette player to
boogie down with awesome mix vol 1
blasting in his ears there's no denying
that right along with the Avengers
themselves that mix is among the best
things Marvel ever assembled with the
compilation going on to become the
second soundtrack ever to sell over a
million digital albums but while
everyone was busy toe-tapping to the
music and laughing at the comical
adventures of quill and company a quiet
little detail slipped right past our
nostalgic eyes star Lords cassette is a
TDK type 2 CD to tape a model that
didn't come out until 1993 that doesn't
make sense
quill was abducted from Earth by yondu
in 1988 so unless the Ravagers chose to
circle back around a few years later to
let quill copy his favorite soundtrack
onto a new tape chances are this mixtape
was a genuine mix
of course regardless of the year it was
made a cassette tape that has been
played for 20 years probably wouldn't be
delivering the crisp digital quality we
heard in the movie anyway
but that's a discussion for another day
spider-man had long been a
mischaracterization
underoos
since then the crime stopper from Queens
has earned his own solo movies and
played an important part in infinity war
it was the first part of spider-man
homecoming though in which the folks at
Marvel had one of their most obvious
face-plants to date it all had to do
with a little time jump that left fans
scratching their heads in bewilderment
in general the MCU tends to follow a
real-life timeline that occurs at or
near the time each movie is released
however in homecoming the movie begins
with a flashback to the aftermath of the
Battle of New York which is supposed to
take place in 2012 it then claims to
jump forward 8 years which would put the
rest of the movie in 2020 this throws it
off from the rest of the MCU timeline
especially considering the fact that it
would put Spidey's first film right
smack dab in the middle of the five-year
snap gap while the webhead sequel does
get back on track by lining up with the
events of the blip the year for the
first film is definitely off kilter and
has even been confirmed by Joe Russo to
be a mistake no that's how it was eight
years I believed sometimes it's the
little details that matter
things like continuity between scenes
details on a costume or filling in
background content with meaningful
information can often take a decent
flick to the next level over the years
the MCU has done a fantastic job in this
regard maintaining both continuity and
impressive details throughout the
complex web of storylines that they've
woven but even the geniuses at Marvel
aren't flawless as was made apparent in
a quick little scene from Iron Man 2
toward the beginning of the film
Tony watches a clip of himself on
c-span's youtube channel the clip is
titled Stark Industries CEO Tony Stark
on Capitol Hill the only problem the
Capitol Hill he's on should be spelled
capi tol but the video spells it al it
may be common to hire editors for the
script but it looks like Marvel may need
to get somebody on board to check
on-screen spelling as well everyone
knows Gamora is awesome and she has one
of the absolute best backstories in the
MCU to boot how many protagonists can
claim to be part of the Thanos family
and still be one of the good guys as
compelling as gamora's origin is though
she's been around long enough now for a
bit of a wrinkle to develop in her
narrative the issue occurred as a result
of the writers attempts to weave her
relationship as Thanos adopted daughter
in with her otherwise busy storyline
the guardians of the galaxy the main
issue here concerns her original people
the scene in guardians of the galaxy in
which the gang is arrested by Nova Corps
is full of a boatload of background info
as well as some typically edgy humor
largely thanks to star-lord during the
scene a small detail flashes up on the
screen for a moment regarding gomorrah's
origin
it states that she's the last survivor
of the Z who bury people of course
anyone who's watched infinity war will
recall that we see Gamora being taken in
by the mad Titan who distracts her as
half of her people are annihilated paths
though what happened to the rest that
would make a more of the last survivor
while explanations could doubtlessly be
cooked up chances are this one is just
an oversight it's easy to excuse
incorrect small details as oversights
but a ton of the Marvel magic takes
place in those very details it's an art
that the MCU has mastered with cleverly
hidden clues and easter eggs building up
so much anticipation for the arrival of
new characters and stories over the
years but even the Masters can stumble
from time to time such is the case with
a brief bit of text that flashes up on
the screen during Captain America the
Winter Soldier as the camera pans across
the Triskelion shield headquarters it
flashes a quick latitude and longitude
graphic on the screen showing where
exactly this impressive building is
located it's the kind of detail that
most viewers would ignore while diehard
fans will take screenshots of it in
order to go look it up later
unfortunately in this case the diehards
won't ever get to know precisely where
shield HQ is located since the on-screen
directions both read his latitude with
one indicating north and the other south
worst reading ever in the scene in
Captain America the Winter Soldier when
Steve Rogers visits the Smithsonian
exhibit about his own life he approaches
a memorial to Bucky Barnes the scene is
overloaded with information so it's hard
to take it all in but at the bottom of
the entry it reads Bucky Barnes 1917 to
1944 set against this however is the
first line at the top of the memorial
which reads born in 1916 okay so which
was it guys the best part about this one
is that the typo takes place on the same
piece of information usually there are a
few movies separating bits of
contradicting information within the MCU
which seems like a reasonable excuse for
when a developing story line goes awry
this time though it appears that someone
simply changed their mind about Bucky's
birth year in the short span of time it
took to write two paragraphs of text and
then never went back to fix the original
date
dr. strange ends up being a pretty cool
guy by the end of his first film and his
appearances in thor ragnarok and
Avengers infinity war only add to his
aura and appeal but of course the
sorcerer supreme started as a cocky
career obsessed doctor that acted like
he owned the world the early sequences
of the movie portray the future master
of the mystic arts as a surgeon at the
very top of his game strutting around
the operating room like he owns the
place but is he really a master of his
craft some have called strangest
surgical skills into question when they
noticed that right in the opening
moments of his solo film Doctor Strange
washes his hands and then puts on his
mask this isn't taking place in the 18th
century but in modern times when it
should be common practice for a surgeon
to not touch anything that could break
the Sterling including his own face the
info should be common knowledge
especially to the best surgeon in town
and yet this accomplished professional
takes his sterile hands and touches his
face right before surgery it's a rookie
mistake that's hardly the sign of a
master of any art form we've already
established the excellence of the
guardians of the galaxy movies but as we
saw with quills cassette deck even films
as good as these aren't impervious to
errors in guardians of the galaxy volume
2 though the air is a bit more obvious
the second installment of the franchise
opens with a little backstory on the
relationship of Peter Quill's parents
with the movie showing ego and Meredith
quill cavorting through the Missouri
countryside as ego leads Meredith down a
slope to show him the alien seedling
he's planted she can be seen fleeting
down the slope behind him in fur capped
boots however a moment later she's shown
next to the strange glowing plant in
sandals was the script continuity
supervisor homesick that day after all
going from winter to summer footwear is
a pretty noticeable difference while the
change is subtle on-screen it's a
mistake that the MCU with all of its
attention to tiny details can't expect
to go unnoticed something is amiss at
the end of the Avengers in one of the
final scenes of the movie as the team
splits up we see each Avenger as they go
their separate ways
heading off to the next great adventure
one of the scenes shows Steve Rogers
dressed down from his Captain America
uniform riding a motorcycle as he
ponders all that's taken place the scene
is serene tranquil and calm a bit too
calm actually after a moment it becomes
glaringly apparent that there's no way
cap is actually riding a real bike
that's moving down the road
many fans point to the fact that his
hair doesn't even budge during the scene
as
that Chris Evans is just sitting still
the truth is though if you look closely
the hair actually does move toward the
end of the clip a little flip caused by
a light draft
however when taken into consideration
this only reinforces the fact that if he
was actually driving at 50 miles an hour
his hair would be flapping all over the
place once you notice Steve's strangely
motionless hair it takes a moment of
cathartic closure and it turns into a
scene that screams green-screen check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]